ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
عمرك عرفت شعور المريض النفسي طب تحب تعرف
بيعيش ازاي او ايه المشاعر اللي بيمر بيها
لو ما تعرفش فانا النهارده اخدك معايا
لرحله في حياتهم في فيلم سيلفر
فيلم مش بيقول لك قد ايه الشخصيات بتعاني
لكنه بيخليك تشوف كل شخصيه ازاي بتتالم في
حياتها فاهلا بيك في حلقه جديده من بودكا
الافلام المقدمه العربيه وكان يا مكان
بتبدا الحكايه بتعب اللي خرج من مستشفى
الامراض النفسيه بعد تمن شهور من عقوبته
اللي دخلها بامر من المحكمه بعد ما خسر
شغله وبيته وزوجته وعلشان تعرف ده حصل ايه
كمل معايا للاخر طب راح بيت اهله وهناك
بتشوف والده اللي خسر وظيفته بسبب عصبيته
وضربه للناس وبقى براهن على المباريات
ونلاحظ انه عنده وسواس وشايف ان تاب مصدر
حظه وبنشوف قد ايه هو ندمان انه ما كانش
بيقعد مع تاب كتير وكان بيهتموا باخوه
اكثر منه وبيقول له انه راهن بكل فلوسه
اللي معاه في المباراه اللي جايه علشان
كده لازم يروح يحضرها علشان يجيب له حظ
حلو وفريقه يكسب وبنشوف كمان ام تاب اللي
من وجهه نظري تعتبر اكتر شخصيه مستقره
نفسيا في الفيلم وبنبدا نشوف ازاي المرض
التاب مؤثر عليه لما بيصحي اهله الساعه
تلاته بالليل لانه كان بيقرا كتاب
والنهايه مش عجباه وازاي ان نيك زوجته
كانت بتدرس الكتاب ده للطلاب وهو راح
للدكتور النفسي وبيسمع هناك اغنيه وبتعصبه
وبيفضل يكسر في العياده لحد ما الاغنيه
تقفل ونشوف قد ايه تاب مش قادر يتحكم في
غضبه بيدخل الجلسه والدكتور بيقول له انه
لازم ياخد الدواء علشان يتحكم في نفسه
اكتر من كده بس بعد بيكون رافض جدا الدواء
علشان بيصيب علامات في جسده وبيبدا يحكي
هو ليه يتعصب لما سمع الاغنيه وبيقول دي
كانت اغنيه فرحي ومره وانا راجع الشغل من
بدري سمعتها في البيت وشفت مراتي بتخوني
وفقدت اعصابي وضربت اللي معاها لحد ما كان
هيموت علشان كده دخلت المستشفى واكتشفت ان
عندي اضطراب ثنائي القطب واتمنعت اني اشوف
نيجي تاني بيجري تاب كل يوم الصبح وهو
لابس كيس من القمامه بيساعده يعرق ويخسر
وزن زي ما نكي زوجته القديمه كانت عايزاه
وبيروح المدرسه اللي كانت شغاله فيها
علشان يشوف نيكي لسه شغاله هناك ولا لا بس
مديره المدرسه بتكون خايفه منه وبترفض
تقول له اي حاجه بيكمل جري وبيشوف صاحبه
راني وبيقرر روني يعزمه على العشا وبيقول
تاب فيرونا كام مراتك بتكرهني لسه بس تعب
بيعرف ان بيرانيكا لسه بيتكلم نيكي وبيقول
له ان دي فرصته علشان يقابل مراته تاني
بيروح العشا وهو لابس تيشرت رياضي وبيحس
ان دي فكره غبيه فبيرجع بس راني بيلحقه
وبيقول له انه بيتمنى يروح عشا وهو لابس
زيه وبيكتشفني اخت فرونيكا هتكون موجوده
على العشاء وبيقول له راني ان جوزها لسه
ميت فما تجيبش سيره الموضوع واول ما بتخش
تقني بيسلم عليها وبيقول لها هو تومي جوزك
مات ازاي بيبدا العشا وبتسال لو بياخد
العلاج وبيقول لها انه بطل ياخده علشان هو
مش بيعرف هو مين وبيبدا يتكلموا عن
الادويه والاعراض بتاعتها ونبدا نعرف
حالتها النفسيه غير مستقره والاحداث
بتتطور بعدها بشكل سريع وغريب
بيحكي لدكتور واللي حصل وبيقول له انه
لازم يلاقي خطه يقدر يسيطر بيها على
مشاعره علشان ما يرجعش المستشفى تاني
وبيطلب تعب من الدكتور انه يوصل رساله لك
بس بيرفض علشان المحكمه منعاه من ده
واقترح عليه ان هو يتقرب من تفني ويبقوا
اصحاب وقتها هتعرف انه بيتحسن بيقتنع فعلا
وبيعمل ده وهو بيجري كالعاده بيقابل تقني
وبيعزمها على العشاء وبيروح ياخدها من
البيت بس اهلها كانوا بيكونوا واقفين
وباصين من الشباك بيوصلوا المطعم وبيطلب
كورن فليكس عشان ما يحسش انه هو في موعد
غرامي او ديت وبيبداوا يتكلموا وبيحكي لها
عن قد ايه نفسه يقابل نيكي ويثبت لها انه
بقى احسن بتقول له ان هي ممكن توصل
الرساله لناكي لو حابب بيتحمس
وقت العشاء هيحصل احداث كتير زي سوق
التفاهم اللي هيحصل ما بينهم وتفني هتقول
لي تعب انه بيتهمها بالجنون
بعد ما كانت اتعصبت وقررت انها مش هتوصل
الرساله بتقرر توصلها
بس بترفض تبعتها وتقول له انها مش هتستفاد
حاجه لو بعتتها فقال لها طب انت عايزه ايه
في المقابل قالت له تقدم معايا في مسابقه
الراس طبعا بيرفض في البدايه لكن بعد كده
بيوافق علشان تبعت الرساله بيبدا تابوت
يتدربوا على الراس بس هو مش بيكون حابب
الموضوع فبتقول له انت عارف جوزي مات ازاي
كان رايح يجيب لي هديه بس شاف عربيه
عطلانه فنزل يساعد اصحابها خبطته عربيه
جايه بسرعه ومات بعدها بيتدربوا على الراس
يوميا وبيقربوا من بعض اكتر واخيرا بيجي
له رد منك ويقرا الرساله وبيكون مكتوب
فيها انها مبسوطه ان هو بيحاول ان هو يحسن
من نفسه بس هي مش هتدي له فرصه تانيه
بيزعل تاب طبعا وبيمشي ايه اللي حصل بعدها
وايه مصير علاقه تابوت وهل علاقه تاب
ووالده هتتحسن رغم الاضطراب النفسي اللي
بيمر بيه ده اللي هتعرفه لما تشوف الفيلم
بس الاهم انك تعرف ان الاضطرابات النفسيه
اكبر من اي شخص وما فيش شخص بيقدر يتحكم
فيها بالكامل الفيلم هيكون مناسب جدا لو
انت مهتم بالامراض النفسيه عايز تفهم ازاي
الناس دي بتعيش فعلا وازاي مشاعرهم بتتغير
من فرح وحزن وحماس وياس في نفس الوقت اما
عن ما وراء فيلم سيلفر لاينز بلاي بوك
فالفيلم خرج لنور سنه 2012 على يد المخرج
العظيم ديفيد المقتبس من الروايه للكاتب
وبيشارك في دور البطوله الممثله جينيفر
وبيعتبر من اعظم الادوار اللي قدمتها في
مسيرتها وكمان الممثل برادي كوبر
للفيلم لابنه واللي الهمه يخرج الفيلم
لانه كان بيعاني من اضطراب ثنائي القطب زي
البطل الفيلم طاقم العمل حصلوا على اكتر
من 35 جائزه من ضمنهم الاوسكار لافضل
ممثله لجنيفر لورنس ام تي في لافضل اداء
افضل ممثله لجني الى كاديميه البريطانيه
الافضل سيناريو ديفيد والروح المستقله
لافضل فيلم والحقيقه مهما احكي لك عنه
محتاج تشوفه وتستمتع بكل مشاهده شوف
الفيلم دلوقتي وما تفوتش عليك واحده من
اعظم الافلام الرومانسيه والدراميه على
الاطلاق كان معكم محمود النجار
واستنوني الحلقه اللي جايه في فيلم جديد
من ما وراء الافلام علشان نحكي عنه
وطريقتنا المختلفه
[موسيقى]